[Musik]
er ist nun vorbei der liebe zuschauer
ihr fett ist bereits den titel
eingeblendet wir machen heute etwas mit
dem digitalen mikroskop so sieht das
ganze aus ich würde ich das gerne zeigen
aber dass kabels nicht so lange das ist
ein digitales mikroskop dass man über
ein usb-kabel an seinen computer
anschließen kann und das hat einen 50
fachen zoom oder auch einen 1000 fachen
zoom
ihr seht hier gerade schon eingeblendet
so sieht meine decke aus allerdings habe
ich hier auch schon einige dinge
vorbereitet die wir uns unter dem
mikroskop anschauen werden ich habe noch
ein blatt vorbereitet ich habe noch ein
klopapier vorbereitet das ist
hoffentlich nicht benutzt und ich würde
sagen mit dem klopapier fangen wir auch
direkt an das heißt ich richte nun das
mikroskop auf das klopapier und
ist es vielleicht doch benutzt
haye ist das piste da also eigentlich
ist es ein frisches stück los
was macht das ist das ende
ich kann das nicht glaube ich auch ein
bisschen dunkler machen
da
wer durch
nur damit ihr mal ein gefühl dafür
kriegt wie weit ich gerade das mikrofon
überhaupt von dem klopapier weg halte es
sind wirklich so 5 cm und mein gott ist
mein finger dreckig wie scheiße das echt
ein bisschen dreckig war damit will ich
sagen kommt auch direkt zum nächsten
gegenstand bzw einfach meine hand das
ist
altach das sieht aus wie eine schlange
also die haut sieht echt bis ca
das ist mein fingernagel
walter ich sehe aus als wäre ich 70
machen wir als nächstes mal die
handinnenfläche
das sind fusseln alter die sind ja so
klein das ist wirklich eine fussel die
ist ein millimeter breit und hier
drunter
wo war so war sowieso da
nee
da hier sieht die autos werden meter
groß waren wir allerdings direkt weiter
und zwar mit einem blatt was ist denn
das
das ist der tomatenketchup also ein
blatt unter dem mikroskop sieht so aus
es sieht jetzt mal umdrehen
das sieht ja richtig co
sagen müsste es ein kunst blatt ist ich
habe keine echten pflanzen in meiner
wohnung weil die alle sterben würden und
das will ich in pflanzen nicht antun
aber ein künstliches blatt sieht so
unterm mikroskop aus ms ist
es ist crazy also wirklich das sieht
echt komisch aussah als nächstes weiter
mit einem stück zwiebel malta also von
der außenseite sind
i
so richtig glücklich
von innen
das ist sie aber das ist ja richtig
ekelhaft aus das ding ist wir können das
auch mal ein bisschen vorstellen hier am
rädchen diesen größen da müssen
allerdings ein bisschen näher herangehen
an die zwiebel und sehen schon wenn wir
hier an der zwiebel sind sehen wie
nämlich dass wir gar nichts
sehen
crazy und da ist wieder ein fingernagel
gefragt ich jetzt wahrscheinlich gerade
halo karmann schaust du dir deine
gesichtshaut mal da
locker so sieht also mein schreibtisch
aus ich werde mir ganz am ende meiner
haut anschauen
ich hab mir nämlich erst mal ein paar
dinge hier vorbereitet und zwar als
nächstes ein stück spargel
m
ja okay das ist jetzt a
hey was kann ich das denn da so viele
punkte drauf hat also der spargel ist
tatsächlich nicht künstlich das ist
echter spargel aber das sieht so
unappetitlich aus dann habe ich noch
eine aufgeschnittene kleine cherry
tomate vorbereitet alles dinge aus
unserem kühlschrank alter das sieht
einfach nur ekelhaft aus
war das ist echt es sieht richtig
ekelhaft aus und als letzten gegenstand
den wir uns unterm mikroskop anschauen
habe ich noch tomatenketchup vor
war
damit war damit das sieht aus als hätte
nie was sind das für schwarze punkte da
drin mit so was esse ich dann immer
meine pöbels
das sieht ja richtig ekelhaft aus nun
haben wir uns aber alle dinge angeschaut
die ich hier vorbereitet habe für das
heutige video und ich würde sagen wenn
ihr lieben freunde ich halte nun dieses
mal in meine fresse hallo
das ist mein alter das ist mein auge
darauf was meinen armen von unten in
meine nase rein schauen andere nasenloch
[Musik]
glaubt aus dem man mal wieder zurück zu
meinem auge
das ist ja
heftig das sieht ja brutal krass aus
allerdings schauen uns jetzt nochmal
meine haut an
im gesicht
die braune
das bad stoppelbart habe ich ja nicht
ein bisschen weiter hier ich weiß gar
nicht wo ich gerade bin bei meiner haut
hier das
dass alle zähne im mund bei mir das ding
auch mal in den mund stecken ein paar
sekunden später
a
hahaha
aha
in einem wahl gewesen
es ist ja alles nicht schlimm es ist
einfach nur der menschliche körper aber
ich glaube ich kann auch mal dieses ding
es hier umstellen und
neu
sorry dass das bild gerade ein bisschen
verwackelt ist aber ich halte das
wirklich so eng wie möglich und ich
halte es auch so ruhig wie möglich aber
das ding ist dass sich halt ganz nah
also sind
es ist ein brutaler zoom guckt euch mal
an wie nah ich gerade an meiner haut bin
aber ich würde sagen wir gehen wir
wieder zurück auf die andere brennweite
1 brennweite und schauen dass man
nochmal meinen mund an
haha szene
ja da ist ein bisschen spucke gewesen
als nächstes würde ich sagen schauen wir
uns mal meine haare an
da sehen wir nämlich fast nichts
wir sind alt haarener
nicht
sondern dich
ach das sind meine doch das war ein auge
können uns ja jetzt auch noch mal mein
bart anschauen
ah da ist
geil alter ja doch ein paar mehr halter
ich habe ich habe ich keine echte
vollbart wachsen lassen immer mit der
ruhe
hier würden gezoomt o mein gott
alter
das ist
barth das erklärt natürlich einiges
alter schwede liebe
das
ja
sorry aber mit der einstellung sieht es
ja brutal krass aus kann ich auch mal
hier irgendwie vielleicht an meiner nase
oder so entlang das ist ja oh
es ist meine nase
das sind mein gott
wie das aussieht
was ist das
das ist blut oder so helga schwede
das sieht ja
total heftig aus unter diesem mikroskop
die sache ist meine lieben zuschauer ich
will hier gar keine werbung machen für
dieses produkt in der ich werde dafür
nicht bezahlt aber ich bin wirklich
begeistert von dieser technik vor allem
weil das teil auch einfach 20 euro
gekostet hat er und schaut euch das an
ich kann das ja meine halt und ihr seht
was hier abgeht
oh mein gott das ist mein auge
das teil es heftig ich halte das ding
jetzt noch mal auf meinen unterarm und
man muss hier wirklich dann so ein
bisschen run justieren damit man das mit
dem xoom so alles
das ist brutal das ist brutal ich halt
kleines muttermal oben ist das nämlich
genau da das ist ja wirklich also das
ist abnormal ich halte das jetzt mal auf
diese ganz kleinen härchen die man noch
seinem finger hat und das sieht dann so
aus
altherr
sorry dass ich hier so oft alter sagen
und so begeistert bin aber ich finds ich
finds krass ihr müsst euch überlegen das
ist so ein kleines ding
das ist so groß dass schließt über kabel
mit einer windows rechnern an einen mac
oder sogar an ein iphone oder android
handy anruft kann sie einfach exakt
angucken was bei der haut ab geht und
ich komisch das aussieht als das was man
will aber im auge ich würde jetzt noch
einmal gern die letzte stufe hier
ausprobieren und zwar weil ich ja gerade
die ganze zeit in der mitte und das hier
das ist das nächste an dass man rangehen
kann
also viel genauer
einzelne wimpern von mir im alter das es
das ist ja brutal ich halte jetzt zum
abschluss noch einmal aufs klo papier
mit dieser krassesten konsum b
warum ist das blau hey warum ist dass da
auch schon wieder die aber das verstehe
ich ja vorn und hinten nicht warum ist
denn das hier gelb und blau und da sogar
ein bisschen rot anders stellt euch das
heutige video ist allerdings auch
beendet meiner lieben zuschauer ich
hoffe euch hat es gefallen ich hoffe ihr
fanden mindestens genauso spannend wie
ich wirklich einfach die eigene haut und
so ein paar gegenstände unter so einem
kleinen 5 cm mikroskop anzuschauen ich
bin komplett begeistert von der technik
wenn euch das video gefallen hat dann
würde ich mich sehr sehr dünn war einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier von
euch freuen und schreibt mir bitte in
die kommentare
ob ich mit diesem mikroskop noch mal ein
video hochladen soll und was ich mir
dann unter dem mikroskop anschauen
sollen also schreibt mir das mal gerne
unten in die kommentare abonniert main
kanal falls noch kein teil der nook seit
und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]